un imam ou une mère --
quand ils m'appellent
après qu'un agent a tiré sur un autre enfant noir non armé,
je comprends un peu la douleur dans leur voix.
C'est la douleur d'un cœur qui se brise
quand il ne parvient pas à résoudre un problème mortel.
Il se brise à essayer de faire une chose
qui semble à la fois nécessaire et impossible.
Ce que l'on ressent en essayant de résoudre le racisme.
C'est nécessaire et impossible.
Les chefs de la police aiment me parler car je suis un expert
mais je doute qu'ils feraient la queue pour aller voir un psy
si je leur disais que c'était sans espoir.
Toutes mes recherches
et la décennie de travail réalisé dans mon centre --
le centre pour l'équité policière --
m'ont mené à une conclusion pleine d'espoir
au milieu du déchirement lié à la race en Amérique
et la voici :
essayer de résoudre le problème du racisme semble impossible
car notre définition du racisme fait paraître cela impossible,
mais cela n'a pas à être ainsi.
Voici ce que je veux dire.
La définition la plus courante du racisme
est que les comportements racistes
sont le résultat de cœurs et d'esprits contaminés.
Écoutez comment nous parlons d'éliminer le racisme
et vous l'entendrez.
« Nous devons éradiquer la haine.
Nous devons combattre l'ignorance. »
Ce sont les cœurs et les esprits.
Le seul problème avec cette définition est qu'elle est complètement erronée --
scientifiquement et autrement.
L'une des idées fondamentales de la psychologie sociale
est que les mentalités sont de mauvais indicateurs des comportements,
mais plus important encore,
aucune communauté noire n'est descendue dans la rue
pour exiger que les gens blancs nous aiment plus.
Les communautés manifestent pour mettre un terme aux tueries
car avec le racisme, il est question de comportements, pas de sentiments.
Même quand les leaders des droits civils
comme King et Fannie Lou Hamer ont utilisé le langage de l'amour,
le racisme contre lequel ils se battaient,
c'était la ségrégation et la brutalité.
Les actions sont plus importantes que les sentiments.
Chacun de ces leaders s'accorderait à dire
que si une définition du racisme
rend cela plus difficile de voir les dommages causés par le racisme,
elle n'est pas qu'erronée.
Une définition qui se préoccupe des intentions des agresseurs
plus que des préjudices aux agressés --
cette définition du racisme est raciste.
Quand nous changeons la définition du racisme
pour passer des mentalités aux comportements,
nous faisons passer ce problème d'impossible à résoluble.
Car vous pouvez mesurer les comportements
et quand un problème est mesurable,
vous exploitez une des règles universelles de la réussite organisationnelle.
Avec un problème ou un objectif mesuré,
vous êtes responsable de cette métrique.
Si toutes les autres organisations mesurent ainsi la réussite,
pourquoi ne pas le faire avec le maintien de l'ordre ?
Il s'avère que nous le faisons déjà.
La police pratique une reddition de comptes basée sur les données,
pour les crimes seulement.
La grande majorité des départements de police à travers les États-Unis
utilise un système appelé CompStat.
C'est un procédé qui, utilisé correctement,
identifie les données criminelles,
il les traque et identifie des tendances
puis il permet aux départements de rendre des comptes
sur des objectifs de sécurité publique.
Il fonctionne soit en dirigeant l'attention ou les ressources de la police
ou en changeant le comportement de la police.
Si je vois une série d'agressions dans un quartier,
je vais vouloir augmenter les patrouilles dans ce quartier.
Si je vois un pic d'homicides,
je vais vouloir parler à la communauté pour découvrir pourquoi
et collaborer pour changer le comportement de la police et diminuer la violence.
Quand vous définissez le racisme en termes de comportements mesurables,
vous pouvez en faire de même.
Vous pouvez créer un CompStat pour la justice.
C'est exactement ce que le centre pour l'équité policière a fait.
Je vais vous dire comment ça marche.
Quand un département de police nous invite,
nous gérons l'aspect légal, discutons avec la communauté,
l'étape suivante est d'analyser ses données.
L'objectif de ces analyses est de déterminer
à quel point la criminalité, la pauvreté, la démographie du quartier
prédisent, disons, l'usage de la force par la police ?
Disons que ces facteurs prédisent
que la police fera usage de la force sur tant de personnes noires.
On y est ?
Notre question suivante est :
combien de personnes noires
sont la cible de l'usage de la force ?
Disons tant de personnes.
C'est quoi l'écart ?
Une grande portion de l'écart est la différence
entre ce qui est prédit par ce que la police ne contrôle pas
et ce qui est prédit par ce que la police contrôle,
ses politiques et ses comportements.
Ce que nous cherchons, ce sont les genres de contact
ou les zones de la ville
où cet écart est le plus important
car nous pouvons dire à nos partenaires :
« Regardez ici. Résolvons d'abord ce problème. »
C'est le genre de thérapie que les chefs de la police soutiennent
car il n'y a rien d'aussi inspirant face à nos antécédents de racisme
qu'un problème résoluble.
Si la communauté à Minneapolis demandait à son département de police
de remédier aux manquements moraux liés à la race au sein de la police,
ils ne sauraient pas faire cela.
Mais si la communauté dit plutôt :
« Vos données indiquent que vous tabassez beaucoup de sans-abri.
Ça vous dit d'arrêter ça ? »
C'est quelque chose que la police peut apprendre à faire.
Et elle l'a fait.
En 2015, le département de police de Minneapolis nous a dit
que sa communauté s'inquiétait d'un usage de la force trop fréquent.
Nous lui avons montré comment exploiter ses données
pour identifier les situations où la force pouvait être évitée.
Regardez ces données,
un nombre disproportionné
de leurs incidents liés à l'usage de la force
impliquait quelqu'un qui est sans-abri, en détresse mentale,
a un problème de toxicomanie ou une combinaison des trois --
plus que ce à quoi vous vous attendriez
d'après ces facteurs dont je vous parlais.
L'écart est juste là.
La question suivante est : pourquoi ?
Il s'avère que les sans-abri ont souvent besoin de services.
Quand ces services ne sont pas disponibles,
qu'ils n'ont pas leur traitement,
ils perdent leur place au refuge,
ils ont plus de risques d'avoir des comportements
poussant des gens à appeler la police.
Quand elle arrive,
ils ont plus de risques de résister à l'intervention,
souvent car ils n'ont rien fait d'illégal,
ils ne font que vivre dehors.
Le problème n'était pas un besoin de former différemment
les agents de Minneapolis.
Le problème était que les gens utilisaient la police
pour « traiter » la toxicomanie et le sans-abrisme.
La ville de Minneapolis a trouvé un moyen d'offrir des services sociaux
et des ressources municipales
à la communauté des sans-abri avant que quiconque n'appelle les flics.
(Applaudissements)
Le problème n'est pas toujours le sans-abrisme.
Parfois, c'est la crainte d'un contrôle de l'immigration,
comme à Salt Lake City ou à Houston,
où les chefs ont dû se manifester :
« Nous ne vous expulserons pas pour avoir appelé la police. »
Ou ce sont les poursuites à pied
comme à Las Vegas,
où ils ont dû former leurs agents à ralentir et à respirer
au lieu de permettre à l'adrénaline de faire dégénérer la situation.
Ce sont les fouilles à Oakland,
le fait de faire sortir les gens de leur voiture à San Jose,
la façon de patrouiller les quartiers
qui composent la zone 3 de Pittsburgh
et les quartiers noirs près des rives à Baltimore.
Mais dans chaque ville,
si nous pouvons leur offrir un problème résoluble,
ils s'affairent à le résoudre.
Ensemble, nos partenaires ont observé en moyenne 25% d'arrestations en moins,
moins d'incidents liés à l'usage de la force
et moins 13% des blessures liées à un agent.
Globalement, en identifiant les plus gros écarts
et en dirigeant l'attention de la police sur leur résolution,
nous pouvons offrir un vaccin
contre les disparités raciales dans le maintien de l'ordre.
Actuellement, nous avons la capacité de nous associer à 40 villes à la fois.
Cela signifie que si nous voulons que les États-Unis arrêtent d'être épuisés
à essayer de résoudre un problème impossible,
nous allons avoir besoin de bien plus d'infrastructure.
Puisque notre objectif est d'avoir les outils pour pouvoir mettre à l'échelle
la brillance d'organisateurs dévoués
et de chefs ayant un esprit de réforme.
Pour en venir là, nous aurons besoin du genre de volonté collective
qui a déségrégué les écoles
et a obtenu le droit de vote pour les enfants d'anciens esclaves
afin que nous puissions créer un système de santé
capable d'offrir notre vaccin à travers le pays.
Puisque notre idée audacieuse
est de fournir un CompStat pour la justice
à des départements qui servent 100 millions de personnes
à travers les États-Unis
au cours des cinq prochaines années.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Faire cela signifierait armer environ un tiers des États-Unis
avec les outils pour réduire les disparités raciales
dans les contrôles, les arrestations, l'utilisation de la force
mais aussi des outils pour réduire les cautions abusives,
l'incarcération de masse,
l'instabilité familiale,
les maladies mentales chroniques, la toxicomanie
et tout autre mal que notre système criminel et légal défaillant aggrave.
Car toute arrestation injustifiée que nous pouvons éviter
sauve une famille du voyage terrifiant à travers chacun de ces systèmes.
Tout comme toute arme pouvant rester dans son étui
sauve une communauté entière d'une vie entière de deuil.
Chacun d'entre nous,
nous mesurons les choses qui nous importent.
Les entreprises mesurent les profits,
les bons étudiants surveillent leurs notes,
les familles font la courbe de croissance des enfants
avec des marques sur l'encadrement d'une porte.
Nous mesurons tous les choses qui nous importent le plus,
c'est pourquoi nous nous sentons délaissés
quand personne ne prend la peine de mesurer quoi que ce soit.
Depuis 250 ans,
nous avons défini les problèmes de la race et du maintien de l'ordre
de façon fonctionnellement impossible à mesurer.
Mais la science dit maintenant que nous pouvons changer cette définition.
Les gens du centre pour l'équité policière,
nous avons peut-être mesuré
plus de comportements policiers que n'importe qui
et cela signifie qu'une fois que nous aurons la volonté
et les ressources pour ce faire,
ce pourrait être la génération
qui arrête d'avoir l'impression que le racisme est un problème insoluble
et voit plutôt
que ce qui est nécessaire depuis bien trop longtemps est possible.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)